okay okay check me in
tickle-tickle-tickle
good morning guys it's a new day yes I'm
wearing the same clothes as yesterday
this morning despite my best efforts
like I have literally been the most
annoying person in this household but
Casey's going out to go get a haircut
and Mama and Papa Chan are going on a
road trip they're going up to not
actually Big Sur but like south of Big
Sur but anyway they're going on like a
four hour road trip and I'm like guys
can you please not go like things are
getting serious in San Francisco
yesterday they reported that they are on
be kind of like mandatory like shelter
in place lockdown where it's like six
counties the place where they're going
isn't part of the lockdown but still
like you don't know how it's gonna
triple down I've been trying to be very
vocal about like the possibilities that
they might get stranded out there and
they're just so chill about it they're
like it's not a big deal if they do do a
lockdown it's not gonna be immediate
they're gonna give us time to get back
we're not gonna get stranded anywhere
and then I'm like okay fine you won't
gets trying to put what if you come in
contact with someone that might have it
and they're like don't even worry about
it we're gonna be going on in nature
we're gonna have our distance from
people if we get hungry we're only gonna
do Drive thrus so yes they're trying to
be precautious but I guess for me and I
should probably stop doing this book
because I keep going on social media I'm
really nervous like I'm scared I don't
want them catching anything because you
know they're older so just I feel like
I'm the only one that's going crazy here
that cares about these people to not go
out into the real world especially
because everyone on social media they're
saying like do your civil duty don't go
outdoors like don't spread it like even
if you feel like you're healthy you're
gonna be doing a disservice to other
people that you could possibly spread it
to if so like guys can you please read
all these articles like please like stay
home but no one's listening to me right
before momma and Poppa Chan are leaving
I asked them can you please at least let
me
take your temperature so we're about to
go do that I understand everything
you're saying
I'm also very worried about the world
right now but at the same time if you
know psychology and everything has ever
told us anything good which is stress is
the ultimate killer of all things and at
least your sickness at least so many
things so the lesser stress unless we
can kind of be aware I think there's a
fine line between being calm and just
being completely stubborn and
hard-headed
I mean oh yeah you're very I'm limiting
my ins and outs and just not really dude
okay you're not limiting it but you're
drinking news because listen you're not
because I think you brought back the
small bottle of white vinegar which is
not a big deal it's just so I can clean
some stuff and you're like oh we need
more vinegar I'll go out and get more
vinegar so you're just really eager to
go out into the world around like you're
not doing your civil duty to stay at
home but I personally think we should
still did like if we need something we
should still be able to do stuff but it
it's only essential yeah until they say
white vinegar to disinfect or not to
clean is not an essential it's not
something that we have to go out okay I
really oh my god you're so on my nerves
like I'm legit like look here with this
this whole situation this is your
patient yeah it starts from my human
it's all the way it's all your the moon
yeah I ran out of patience for this
topic it's been like three days of me
trying to you're gonna let me take your
temperature before you leave please
I just I care about you guys I don't
want you excuse it I don't want you guys
going out into the real world
and then you might possibly be having a
fever which you don't realize and then
it might get worse and I just don't want
that to happen
okay now cleaned and disinfected who
wants to go first
oh yeah under your tongue it's an old
school
you press this 103 already man yeah good
yeah
what's this in your mouth that's when
you press the button under your tongue
movie in what if I do I have a faulty
one oh my goodness right when we need it
let me shake it nice table for us the
cult was bad what this means not
[Laughter]
marijuana do I wash it with cold water
that's why I was you you just infect
yourself before you come inside the
house thank you spoil yourself just
kidding I said boil oh you know how you
could like water or whatever so no hot
water
yeah no I'm kidding spray Lysol all over
yourself ninety seven point seven point
nine ninety eight point one way it's
going up ninety eight point two all your
ninety eight points it okay you guys are
good okay that makes me feel better you
guys are happy too so when I come back I
will be 90 yes no not me a point dude
all right well I love you guys
actually yes I called behave also the
time we'll be in the car and in them
hotel room yeah this is and then and
then probably just the nature to buy the
good nature trail by the whole thing is
fine - sure that's true on the beach
yourself well enjoy yourselves didn't be
safe and I was just the three of us know
what are you planning to do what should
we do with it were the only good boys
and girls here not leaving well do you
say yeah when they left
alright bikes around the community yes
but it's a small community there's no
one outdoors we can't we're not coming
into contact with people so let's go
ride a bike alright update on the bike
riding before we went out I realized I
didn't finish doing the dishes so I ran
the dishwasher that's going and then
tonight because we have the foldable
bikes so we built up both of our bikes
and like we put our helmets on we even
went outside and like we closed the
garage door and everything we were about
to start writing but then that's when we
noticed that all of the tire all four
tires are completely flat so we're like
oh man we can't even go but luckily a
few days ago I ordered an automatic air
pump kind of thing for my car because my
car's tires have like low air pressure
so I bought it about a week ago I think
and luckily today the air pumps supposed
to be coming in so within a couple hours
we should have that air pump we will
pump up the tires and then do our little
bike ride because Isaac is so bored I
feel for the kid and so now we're just
trying to figure out like okay what else
can we do around the house so what we're
gonna do now is measure his bedroom
because we still haven't ordered his
bedroom set and we're gonna measure the
bedroom check out the dimensions of the
bedroom set that we want to get and then
order that online and hopefully it comes
in within the next week and then we can
build it out and then Isaac doesn't have
to be sleeping on the floor anymore so
that's the current update it is like the
house feels a lot lonelier like it feels
lonelier now there's just me and Isaac
because at least we've been used to
having Casey here but then at one point
having up to nine people in the house
and then now it's just down to the two
of us I feel it I feel the emptiness of
the home trying to figure things out to
keep Isaac stimulated because all the
kid wants to do is just play video games
and I'm like that's cool for a couple
days here and there but you get some
point where it's like okay we got to do
something else alright so this is the
room situation that we got going on we
pulled out a few tape measures so you
can see like all right this is Isaac's
new bedroom set and then this is the the
length no the width
no the depth the depth of Isaac's new
desk
but yeah it's funny because we're using
his clothing as like kind of markers to
to see where the dimensions of things
are gonna be checkout the drawing so
this is a rough draft we I had Isaac
draw out his room and then
see like the bed but then this is the
final dress this is where his desk is
probably gonna be or maybe over here and
then this is his chair his desk chair
and this is gonna be a different piece
of furniture we were about to get some
dressers but we realized it actually
doesn't fit so this would be a different
piece of furniture his new bed frame a
nightstand and we might be getting
another night scent on this side so you
can head out so he can have two
nightstands and then I also got a look
into getting him a rug so you can try to
salvage this carpet as much as pop or
not salvage but keep it nice as long as
possible
Oh
what do we have here do you see some
eyeballs some shining eyeballs look how
cute she likes hiding in your hamper oh
did she know she jumped in there sure
you could jump out do you want to help
her get out look you're gonna get out
you nosy girl yeah this is Isaac's
current dresser situation so yeah this
boy needs furniture hey you rescued her
are you okay are you okay my new you
silly girl much I'm gonna bet my eyes me
groaning again I know though is in there
earlier
maybe they they're the ones that ripped
it yeah what do you think about the
layout of your your room with the
furniture situation okay yeah I know we
can all build it together you know we
could have some building IKEA furniture
family time right now because I have a
dresser I need a build it's right over
here
all these boxes is for one dresser gonna
help me build that next yeah okay well
when is what is the air pressure didn't
come
oh the title for the tires I don't know
it's pretty soon I got a notification
that it's like ten stops away so that
was a while ago so maybe it's closer you
bored are you bored too when we're
walking
we went to your room right mm-hmm I saw
him he's about to pass out
do you know as I was walking and then
he's right here right oh he was sleepy
you know he's been like extra like
sleepy and I don't know he's just he's
not usually this lethargic but he's also
been extra cuddly I think he's happy
that we've been home all these days what
you guys done
that's wrestling yeah look at a
wrestling of that MMA oh he's getting
smarter dude now he's more of an
opponent because when he was younger you
could just mess around but now you have
too much right now
now you should be afraid to be very
afraid for me tell you it nope okay okay
grab his arm tickle the sack your
favorite Isaac who's your favorite it
really is his favorite by the way I'm
not saying that sarcastically I might be
a baby he actually likes you he loved
this is Heather strong I know when she
gets so strong don't break my fingers
you got strong boy he gave up oh I got
you break yours don't be hating you push
them what oh I'm spinning I didn't catch
a camera but you're spinning like a dog
hey what happened here oh you just need
me oh my gosh but I need you I think so
or something something hit me in the
face
honey bleep no you have like a red spot
yeah we see you are you okay let me see
I'm the referee I'm like okay and he
makes and he could and wait
Oh weapons weapons now because disabled
what happened oh you're still tickling
you can't see the ponies and brick all
right so the air compressor just came in
we unboxed it here it is now we're gonna
see if it works on the back tires and
also I have to point out by the way the
Sun came out it's such a gorgeous day
now lose this beautiful I love it it's
making me feel a lot nicer I think you
wanna help me come on over come on over
come on over baby bit scary you don't
know that song huh it's a way before
your time my child I don't think so
I think we just unscrew this thing here
to screw it in no just push it in I
think just make sure you don't drop the
base does that work hold any weight
actually I loosen that and I'm never
doing good and then oh wait let go oh it
was really fast
no it's are you done whoa it stops
automatically I think oh wait no no way
press the button again wait maybe I
should go with the tire pressure should
be all right so we just pulled up the
airs I mean what so we just filled up
the tires with air okay so I tried
googling what tire pressure is
appropriate for this type of bike I came
to an answer of a range so I don't know
this thingamabob er is supposed to be
able to
tell me the PSI as soon as I connect it
to the bike but it wasn't it was only
telling me the amount of pressure that
it had added to the bike so without
knowing the exact psi of the bike I'm
kind of concerned that we may have put
too much air in it so I tried releasing
some air but I don't know man I don't
know we will see what happens because we
don't want too much air right I heard
that's a bad thing so I don't know this
is how flat it currently is this is
after putting air in so I'm like I don't
know it seems about right
[Music]
does it feel like before do you think
it's maybe too much air oh that's why
cuz the gears
alright so Isaac's strategy is to try to
release as much air as possible and then
the machine should be accurate
twenty nine it's what field let's see oh
yeah maybe that's too much that's good
think I mean I don't know I do have you
have to make it bouncy okay so I do have
a tire psi checker like a digital one
that I had from my Honda and I gave it
to Casey so he could use for his car but
he put it in his dresser or something or
in the office and it's stuck in one of
these boxes so that's the reason why I'm
like uh I wish I had it handy so I could
just check the PS I know for a fact the
actual number I think your plan might
have work where it could have just aired
out or like drained out all the air and
then see what amount of psi the things
the actual compressor gave us oh yeah it
has to be open I think you got it oh
it's going in yeah you don't wanna push
too hard oh yeah that's really flat
so we're just buying it not even relying
on those numbers anymore
nice good job baby yeah by the way happy
st. Patrick's Day happy st. Patrick's
Day I remembered because of my green
nails
well let me like it's a pinch you
there's your pinch didn't work green
today that was just so weird guy needed
after being home for four days and not
moving relax yeah I'm your child you
have a lot of energy to exert I'm an old
lady you know be good right now hmm
yes Ducky's I can't do it anymore man
my stomach because the other day way to
hoping to that game uh-huh my stomach
was burning I'm like I can't do this
anymore you can enjoy something let's go
alright it's lunchtime oh yeah no way
you were back already yeah you're
wrestling but your hair that looks great
yeah
was it worth exposing yourself to the
outside world the dangerous you feel
refreshed true ready to take on the
world
I'm still better with a haircut that's
good you look good thank you baby
we have an accident has an accident of
like a telling okay accident go away
carry on
we are filet mignon mm-hmm
that we'll be dining with today we have
the rice that this can wait this is
gonna tell you like that no I'm just
gonna if in European accent no it's a
fancy ID yeah you know the famous
restaurants they're like telling you oh
right we have some macaroni and cheese
me and cheeks hmm we also have those
leftovers from last night and we have
Louisiana chicken Popeyes / biscuit
biscuit biscuit during the dining
experience we'll have some dick plus
some entertainment entertainment is the
first time we're using the TV where we
actually tilted it towards the dinner
table so so get to do that
Hey hey guys
so after we had lunch I ended up doing a
group FaceTime oh no he's coughing now
you're coughing now he's got that Corona
no I've been coughing all day too so I'm
like what do you mean a trio it's a
really serious thing that people are
dying for what do you mean it ain't real
you sound like you're dead no not for
our eyes but us thinking were sick
that's okay that's I got had to clarify
because it sounded insensitive can you
daddy possibly stay at a hotel
you're kicking us out after lunch I did
a group FaceTime call with the girls to
kind of check in with everyone see what
everyone's doing Gina was streaming so
she missed out but that's what I did and
then it was just a lot of being lazy
honestly we were just laying in bed
watching guardians of galaxy as chilling
but Isaac and I we were doing like a
little play fighting thingy
and like tickling and it was so funny
cuz I don't know where he just starts
what was the part that you kept like he
was actually singing lyrics and I was
like wait I recognize those lyrics and
then he goes in case you don't know
where that's from it's from a bad lip
reading video of Star Wars
it's like Yoda singing and I think the
title is something about seagulls but it
was so put ha ha
it was so funny because I think knows
the lyrics to it I'm like you remembered
that he was like it's a catchy song so
we've been singing it there's like the
past two hours
oh and then it was funny too because as
we were in tickle fighting he kept
elbowing the crap out of me I'm like
dude you and Danny always elbow me and
then Isaac goes well that's funny
because I never have elbow problems with
elbowing columns with Daddy and I'm like
yeah it's cuz you guys have such and
this big output and matt has been
cracking Isaac up your misogynistic
elbows maybe can you even breathe you
wrecked your whole head again breathe my
son breathe I wanna be on camera oh you
don't
okay now just die you're kidding yeah
you don't have to be on camera if you
wanted I wash my face a beautiful face
oh I saw it I saw a comment that someone
said hey Isaac's turning into a real
black bowl you don't know but boys know
like a cute guy I think you let's go
yeah dude his voice is so deep like
every day it's getting deeper deeper and
older my boy wait the words and lyrics
do you remember no your singing I forgot
haha fine I'm being that mom that's like
come on do that thing that you showed us
at home do the thing anyway Casey's been
editing right that's been your whole day
today that's kind of funny
that's a consummated what are you
getting editing so Antoine doesn't enjoy
the Edit
and then he'll send me his final and
then sometimes I'm like I'm sure this
one goes up on tweak it a little bit
more that's what I'm doing right now
what were you editing today Tina earlier
today on majority today with editing big
mood big moon yeah
what's in a podcast it was a special
special something something yeah it's
our new segment that we're releasing do
you guys remember a few weeks ago I
don't even know if it was it's been
weeks now but we rented out an air B&B
and then we all had like this really
gigantic sleepover and it was really fun
but during that sleepover Lee films
content we're creating like a new
segment or like kind of like a youtube
series kind of content where it's not so
much a podcast but like short form
content so Casey is editing the first
one and it's one where all the girls we
all build a fort
because nikki has never had a sleepover
before in the past and then later when
we find out that Gina also I have never
had to sleep like a slumber party so
yeah it was a really fun video so
Casey's been working on that and by the
time you guys see this vlog that video
will have already been out so go make
sure to go check it out check out big
mood that's been our date today and yeah
tomorrow will be a new day and
self-quarantine land but we'll see you
guys tomorrow
good night
[Music]